Sure. I'm Jason Zutty.
I'm a research engineer at
the Georgia Tech Research Institute in the Electro-Optical Systems Lab,
and we are working today on a SMART protocol for appendicitis,
which is a data-driven approach to guiding a patient through
their post-operative care to get them the best outcomes in the shortest length of stay.
Correct.
There have been several traditional protocols implemented.
They've been kind of expert guided so doctors will sit around the room and
kind of decide the key decision points in a patient's care.
Our approach is to be data-driven and patient-specific so
you'll be guided through care similar to patients,
most similar to you.
So, if anyone had good results,
it'll kind of guide yours and the protocol will continue to
evolve as more data is taken in the hospital setting.
Purpose of the SMART protocol
is to standardize care so we're looking for
a disease or surgery that affects as many children as possible,
and is fairly regular and easy to standardize.
So appendicitis affects over 80,000 children a year,
and we've been working with Children's Healthcare of Atlanta,
which has a data set of roughly 1,200 appendectomies performed every year.
So that's a good big data area to look at and it's a fairly standard thing to care for.
Yes.
We're looking at complicated appendicitis or perforated appendicitis,
which occurs in about 40 percent of
the appendicitis surgeries that are happening at CHOA.
We're looking at this in particular because they have a much higher rate of
negative outcomes and a longer hospital stay,
which are both opportunities for quality improvement,
improving the negative outcomes,
and reducing the length of stay.
The reason that this is the case is because we find that wound in infection, sorry,
wound infection and abscess rates occur at about 5-25 percent
depending on the patient and readmission rates are approaching 15 percent,
for perforated appendicitis care.
And we find that there's lots of variation that can be standardized,
from the use of diagnostic imaging,
to laboratory tests all the way to which kinds of catheters are used,
in all sorts of components of their care.
So the goal is to standardize those,
and get the patient out as fast as possible without,
well while reducing the risk of readmission rates.
So the data sources we're using are approximately, or exactly,
we're using six years of data from CHOA,
From 2009-2014, that have been collected and disseminated to us directly from CHOA.
It comes from two different locations,
which is Egleston and Scottish Rite,
two CHOA campuses in Atlanta.
And we have more than 120 what we call features,
collected from pre-intra and post-operative care.
From that data set,
we're trying to identify the negative outcomes,
which we have defined to be an occurrence of a UTI,
sepsis, deep organ space SSI,
superficial SSI or pneumonia.
Whether or not if a follow up procedure was performed,
which we call a re-operation,
if the patient returned to the emergency room after discharge,
which is also call a return to the system,
and if the patient was readmitted to the hospital,
which is your readmission.
From our entire cohort,
we had about 6,000 appendectomy cases which
3,000 by our definition were deemed to be complicated or perforated,
which we used a metric of how long they stay in the hospital to identify that,
which was greater than two days,
which is a standard approach.
And of the 3000 cases that were perforated,
we had 705 examples of negative outcomes for the perforated cases.
We are using machine learning.
There's a reason where there's a little story here,
which is we started with the idea of being able to find all these key decision points,
in their care protocol.
But the problem is, the resolution of our data.
You don't have necessarily the points we need.
What we want to be able to do is
say when their daily temperature reaches a certain amount
or falls below you know when they haven't had a fever for
a day and they're tolerating a good diet and all,
and you know we've come up with some metrics discharge.
Otherwise, keep them another day.
If their white blood cell count falls below this, order this test.
Unfortunately, we don't have the kind of AB testing or
the resolution and the daily data to be able to identify key points yet.
They've started collecting that.
In the meantime, the key part of the SMART protocols can be able to kind of
predict whether or not they're going to
have a negative outcome or what their length of stay is going to be.
So, along that vein,
we started doing machine learning.
The other thing that kind of plays into this is
that we have to present it to the user directly so machine learning,
we have 120 features collected and we can achieve some pretty good statistics using that.
My research, in particular,
is in the automated algorithm design,
which is combining machine learning techniques together using
genetic programming to design all sorts of algorithms pipelines that would
help minimize the false negatives and
false positives and try and get our best kind of area under the curve that we can.
But we can't ask 120 questions to the patient by presenting them with
an iPad so we need something that runs fast in
between each question and kind of prioritizes
the questions so we get the best resolution in to
our data without overburdening the particular patient or overgeneralizing the model.
We can't run a machine learner in between each question to try and find
the next question and things like that so we have to be kind of
fast, and we have a lot of data.
Instead, we built a collaborative filtering kind of approach or a filtering model,
which basically goes through and correlates
each feature with whether or not they had a negative outcome,
and the most predictive variables are presented as
the next question and each time the data is filtered down.
So that's the approach we took.
The results have been pretty good so far,
in terms of the first cut.
There's plenty of room for improvement.
The data is split by years into training data and validation data.
We used four years for training data,
which were 2009, 2010, 2012,
and 2013 and our validation data was 2011 and 2014.
The way we did this was we had the validation data kind of enumerated so each patient in
the validation data set kind of would have walked through
the predictive model that sits on top of the training data.
We found that we had a very very low false positive rate,
which corresponds to a 97 percent specificity,
but on the flip side of that we had a pretty low sensitivity,
or a high false negative rate of about 75 percent.
We think this is mainly due to the fact that we kind of lumped
all the negative outcomes together for this first pass,
which we did because we needed to have a kind of
good cohort of what is a negative outcome.
If we split up any particular vector at this point,
so we're looking at just re-admissions,
if we're looking at just signs of infection or sepsis,
we found that we didn't have as many negative cases.
You need the kind of the predictive power behind it to do
a good predictive model so we lumped it all together.
As we continue to collect more data,
we think that these statistics are going to improve.
The positive predictive value or
precision was about 58 percent so that your confidence in your prediction.
So when you say it's going to be a negative outcome,
you're about 60 percent sure,
which is better than a coin toss.
We also had a very strong negative predictive value,
so when we say that it's not going to be a negative outcome,
we're 88 percent sure that.
This resulted in a model of an overall accuracy of 87 percent.
We definitely want to get
the app that we've developed so far in the hands of clinicians
and families to kind of get some feedback as to how is the interface for it,
are the predictions it's giving useful,
is the information it's conveying useful as the quality of those predictions?
We also want to continue to collect more data,
especially some timers all data so get some daily ideas
of how well patients are tolerating meals,
what the daily maximum temperature is to find if they've become afebrile,
which means that their fever has cleared and things like that,
which would be helpful in designing the SMART protocol.
We also want to explore alternatives to the filtering model or ways to improve it,
may be balancing the correlations between the negative outcomes and the length of stay,
and things of that nature.
We're also kind of looking at this point for extramural funding.
Sure.
The first part of that is the filtering model that we have behind it.
The filtering model is going to be
basically trying to minimize the number of questions presented to the user and it
does that by asking questions based on which features are
most correlated towards negative outcomes for a particular patient.
As you go through,
if the question has a numeric answer it's going to
basically throw out half the data set which is furthest away from
the current patient and maintains
the cohort patients that are most similar to your answer.
If the question is a non-numeric answer,
it's going to down select down to the answers that match from the cohort.
At any given time, it's going to basically display the statistics
for the remaining data and how it splits up
based on the future choices that the patient will make.
Here's an example of our initial three questions that are presented to the user.
These have been shown to have some predictive power but they're also deemed
necessary by the medical staff so they're expertly
guided questions as data that we need to collect.
We prompt with three questions at the beginning,
which is how many years old is the patient,
how long have they been in the hospital,
and what type of appendectomy did they have,
being laparoscopic or open?
Once they ans- answer those questions,
the data will be filtered and
the most predictive feature will be identified in the question.
Discriminating that feature will then be asked and so if we carry on like this,
eventually we'll get something along the lines.
What we see here, where
we've gone through several questions at this point in our current question is,
what antibiotic were they given prior to their surgery?
Here, we can see on the top there
current kind of cohort based on all the questions that have answered so far,
how many patients are similar to them,
still in the data set,
what's their average length of stay,
and what's their probability of a negative outcome?
Then we also show right below that kind of the confidence intervals.
These are the bounds on a 95 percent confidence interval.
The opacity here indicates the tightness of
that confidence interval so the tighter the confidence interval
the darker the shade of the particular cell,
while the color is indicating the performance
of a particular choice relative to where you are now.
You can see here for example that meropenem
has a much higher percentage of negative outcomes so that is going to be
a more orange warning sign than
the cool blue that indicates everything is getting better or about the same.
Here, you can see all the different choices that you can
input and how they kind of affect the data behind it.
You're welcome. Thanks for having me.